Thousands of children under the age of 15 have been directly involved in the conflict in Sierra Leone. United Nations Refugee Agency says it believes soldiers, loyal to the former military regime, are holding many civilians as hostages. For more than a decade, the West African nation of Sierra Leone was ravaged by a brutal civil war. The fighting was triggered by the refusal of the hunter. In the struggle for control of the West African nation, since last month's brutal rebel attack on the capital free-town. Children as young as seven were given machetes and machine guns and forced to become killers.
成千上万名15岁以下的儿童直接卷入了塞拉利昂的冲突。联合国难民署表示，他们认为忠于前军政府的士兵扣押了许多平民作为人质。在过去的十多年里，西非国家塞拉利昂一直饱受残酷内战的蹂躏。这场战斗是由猎人的拒绝引发的。在争夺这个西非国家控制权的斗争中，自从上个月反派残酷袭击首都弗里敦以来，年仅七岁的儿童就被发给砍刀和机枪，被迫成为杀手。
From systematic amputation of limbs to mass rape, murder, and enslavement of the civilian population, some election days are more momentous than others. the amputation of limbs to mass rape, murder, and enslavement of the civilian population. Some election days are more momentous than others. For example, today in Sierra Leone, the West African nation is attempting to elect a legitimate government after a decade of brutal civil war in the first multi-party election there in 25 years. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta.
从系统的肢体截断到大规模强奸、谋杀和对平民人口的奴役，有些选举日比其他日子更重大。肢体截断到大规模强奸、谋杀和对平民人口的奴役。有些选举日比其他日子更重大。例如，今天在塞拉利昂，这个西非国家正在经历25年来的第一次多党选举，试图在经历十年的残酷内战后选出一个合法政府。这里是隐藏的大脑，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
Today we're talking about reconciliation. Now when we talk about forgiveness, we usually mean forgiving minor violations. It's one thing to forgive someone who says something offensive or steals your purse or accidentally crashes a car into yours. But could you forgive a neighbor who kills your father or cuts off your hand? Could you continue to live next door to that person? Could you go back to being just neighbors?
今天我们来谈谈和解。现在，当我们谈论宽恕时，通常是指原谅轻微的违规行为。原谅一个说了冒犯性话语、偷了你的钱包或不小心把车撞到你车上的人是一回事。但你能原谅一个杀死你父亲或砍掉你手的邻居吗？你能继续和这个人住在隔壁吗？你能回到只是普通邻居的关系吗？
I was always fascinated by this question of how we can restitch the fabric of society in the aftermath of war. This is Andrella Dubé. She is an assistant professor of political science and economics at New York University. And here's the question she set out to answer. Can there really be reconciliation after atrocities on the scale seen in Sierra Leone? Over 50,000 people were killed, thousands more were raped and amputated, and a lot of this
我一直对这样一个问题着迷：在战争之后，我们如何重塑社会的结构。这是安德雷拉·迪贝。她是纽约大学政治学和经济学助理教授。以下是她着手解答的问题：在塞拉利昂这样规模的暴行之后，真的能实现和解吗？超过5万人丧生，数千人遭到强奸和截肢，其中许多
violence was actually neighbor on neighbor. So when a conflict like this came to an end, you could find yourself living next door to someone who is responsible for amputating you or for hurting your family members. And the question that I really wanted to ask is, how does a community move on from something like this? I was a small boy when the war entered my village. This is Numa, he's from a small village in East Tansierra, Leone. Everyone packed their bags and began to flee to Guinea.
暴力实际上是邻居对邻居的伤害。因此，当这样一场冲突结束时，你可能会发现自己和那个负责对你进行截肢或伤害你家人的邻居住在隔壁。我真正想问的问题是，一个社区如何从这样的事情中走出来？当战争进入我的村庄时，我还只是个小男孩。这是努马，他来自塞拉利昂东部的一个小村庄。每个人都收拾好行李，开始逃往几内亚。
I began to go, I began to go, I began to go. I began to go, me. We met the rebels on the road. They looked at me keenly and said, no. They said, let me not pass again. They would not let me pass. I was captured. So me being one of me, brother. While I was with them, they also captured my friend by the name Saur.
我开始走，我开始走，我开始走。我开始走，我。我们在路上遇到了叛军。他们敏锐地看着我，说不。他们说，不让我再通过。他们不让我过去。我被俘虏了。所以我作为我自己的一部分，我的兄弟。我和他们在一起时，他们还抓了我的朋友绍尔。
I knew Saur very well. We grew up together. And here is Saur, new must childhood friend. This war really destroyed me. When the rebels invaded, they captured me in the bush, and my father too. You're hearing two producers read subtitles from a documentary made by a nonprofit group called Catalyst for Peace. The rebels asked Numa to do something terrible. It was part of a systematic pattern they were using to turn friend-on-friend, neighbor-on-naber, and destroy the social ties that held communities together. They commanded me to beat him up. I refused and said, this is my friend, I won't do it.
我非常了解绍尔。我们一起长大。这就是绍尔，努马童年的朋友。这场战争彻底毁了我。当叛军入侵时，他们把我和我父亲一起在丛林里抓获。你听到的是两个制作人宣读由一个名为“和平催化剂”的非营利组织制作的纪录片中的字幕。叛军要求努马做一件可怕的事。这是他们用来挑拨朋友、邻居，并摧毁凝聚社区的社会纽带的系统性模式的一部分。他们命令我殴打他。我拒绝了，并说，这是我的朋友，我不会这么做的。
But the rebels weren't making a request, they were issuing a command. A rebel fighter raised his gun and aimed it at Numa. So what was the name of the family? Then they shot me. The bullet pierced Numa on his right side just at the hip. Numa felt he had no option. He turned on his childhood friend. That was Buddha.
但叛军不是在请求，而是在下达命令。一名叛军战士举起枪，瞄准了努马。那么这个家庭叫什么名字？然后他们开枪打了我。子弹击中了努马右侧的臀部。努马觉得别无选择。他将矛头指向了他童年的朋友。那是布达。
I beat him. The rebels handed Saur a knife. They gave me a knife and told me to kill my father. But I told them I wouldn't kill my own father. The rebels handed the knife to Numa. At gunpoint, they ordered him to kill Sars' father. Fearing for his own life, Numa took the knife. He slit the throat of his friend's father.
我打了萨尔。叛军递给绍尔一把刀。他们给了我一把刀，叫我杀了我父亲。但我告诉他们我不会杀我自己的父亲。叛军把刀递给了努马。在枪口下，他们命令他杀死绍尔的父亲。由于担心自己的生命安全，努马拿起了刀。他割断了他朋友父亲的喉咙。
But in my mind, I thought my friend would not blame me. I was forced to do it. After the war was over, a nonprofit group named Fumble Talk began to organize reconciliation ceremonies in different villages. Fumble Talk is a career for family. And it's an old tradition. It's as old as a family. It's safe. There is an actual reconciliation ceremony that takes place, which is a two-day event, where people from these ten villages in this community come to participate. Andrella was working with another nonprofit group called
但在我心里，我认为我的朋友不会责怪我。我是被迫这么做的。战争结束后，一个名为“Fumble Talk”的非营利组织开始在不同的村庄组织和解仪式。“Fumble Talk”是家庭的载体。这是一个古老的传统。它和家庭一样古老。它是安全的。这是一个实际举行的为期两天的和解仪式，来自该社区这十个村庄的人们都来参加。安德雷拉当时正与另一个名为
Innovations for Poverty Action, which was active in Sierra Leone. When Andrella heard about Fumble Talk's work, she was immediately intrigued. Steeped in tradition, the reconciliation ceremonies call for community members to confront one another in a public setting, admit to wrongdoing, and seek forgiveness from people they have heard. And in this ceremony where there's a bonfire around this bonfire, victims actually testify to the atrocities they experienced, perpetrators admit to crimes and seek forgiveness, but
“消除贫困创新”的非营利组织合作，该组织在塞拉利昂很活跃。当安德雷拉听说“Fumble Talk”的工作时，她立刻被吸引了。这些植根于传统的和解仪式呼吁社区成员在公共场合面对彼此，承认错误，并向他们伤害过的人寻求宽恕。在这个仪式上，篝火旁，受害者实际上公开讲述了他们经历的暴行，加害者承认罪行并寻求宽恕，但
a very important component is no one is prosecuted or otherwise punished for participating. Numa and Saur attended a fumble talk gathering. By now, they were young adults. One of the boys who stepped forward and testified talked about the experience that he had during the war when he, his friend and his father were taken into the backwoods by the rebel groups. People clashed out around a bonfire. Saar stepped forward to speak. The man that did this to me is here. I saw him.
一个非常重要的组成部分是，没有人会因为参与而被起诉或受到其他惩罚。努马和绍尔参加了“Fumble Talk”的聚会。此时，他们已经是年轻的成年人了。其中一个站出来作证的男孩谈到了他在战争期间的经历，当时他、他的朋友和父亲被叛军带到树林深处。人们在篝火旁发生冲突。萨尔站出来说话。对我做这件事的人就在这里。我看到了。
The man that beat me and killed my father is here. The man who did this to me is here. He's right there. This is the man. Saar points to Newman. At the time that he said the person who did this, he's here in the audience, he became quite emotional and he actually approached the other boy seemingly in a kind of moment of anger and one of the others in the village stepped forward, pulled him back a little bit to ensure that they didn't actually engage in some sort of you know physical tussle. So there was a very tense moment where they were very close to each other and the boy who had actually committed this crime and admitted.
打我并杀了我父亲的人就在这里。对我和做这件事的人就在这里。他就在那儿。这个人就是他。萨尔指向纽曼。当他说做这件事的人就在观众席中时，他变得相当激动，甚至似乎在愤怒的时刻走向了另一个男孩，村里的其他人之一站出来，把他拉回来一点，以确保他们不会发生某种物理上的争执。因此，这是一个非常紧张的时刻，他们离得非常近，而那个真正犯下罪行并承认的男孩。
They gave me a knife to kill his father. I took that knife and cut his father's throat. But what I did was not much choice. Not so easy on a young man like you. Please forgive me. I'm looking at him, Haka for us. And then the boy whose father had been killed said, and I had named how I'm on Gunggyumpe. I have accepted and I have agreed to forgive him.
他们给我一把刀去杀他父亲。我拿着那刀割了他父亲的喉咙。但我所做的没有多少选择。对像你这样的年轻人来说并不容易。请原谅我。我看着他，Haka for us。然后那个父亲被杀的男孩说，我叫什么Gunggyumpe。我已经接受并同意原谅他。
I don't accept him. I'll forgive him. Forgive me. Forgive me. Forgive me. Forgive me. Forgive me. Forgive me. Forgive me. Forgive me. Forgive me. Forgive me. Forgive me.
我不接受他。我原谅他。原谅我。原谅我。原谅我。原谅我。原谅我。原谅我。原谅我。原谅我。原谅我。原谅我。原谅我。
Forgive me. Forgive me. So this was one of the most, you know, kind of striking examples that has always stayed with me and there are many other accounts like this. Sometimes they're not always so easily resolved. There's more tension that flares up as their accounts are being told and emotions run high. So this is the type of account that takes place. When we come back, we'll tell you more about what happened to Numa and Sarr, and also
原谅我。原谅我。所以这是最引人注目、一直留在我的记忆中的例子之一，还有很多类似的故事。有时它们并不总是那么容易解决。当他们的故事被讲述时，更多的紧张局势会爆发，情绪高涨。这就是这种叙述发生的方式。当我们回来时，我们将告诉你更多关于努马和绍尔的故事，以及
examine the counterintuitive effects of the reconciliation ceremonies in Sierra Leone. Going through these memories of war in a short, intense fashion can actually reopen some old wounds. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. We're talking with Andrela Dubay today. She's an assistant professor of political science and economics at New York University. Andrela finds that traditional forgiveness ceremonies after brutal atrocities can achieve the kind of reconciliation between neighbors that many of us might consider impossible.
审视塞拉利昂和解仪式的反直觉效果。以一种简短、强烈的方式重温这些战争记忆，实际上可能会重新打开一些旧伤。请继续收听。这里是隐藏的大脑，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。今天我们与安德雷拉·迪贝交谈。她是纽约大学政治学和经济学助理教授。安德雷拉发现，残酷暴行之后的传统宽恕仪式可以在邻居之间实现我们许多人认为不可能实现的和解。
The ceremonies don't just affect the individuals involved, they have a big impact on community ties and cohesion, what researchers would call social capital. You know, what we find is that the reconciliation process was inordinately successful in healing the community. So we've talked about forgiveness in this particular anecdote. But when we look at the data, we find that it actually fostered forgiveness on a widespread level. We have these measures from the psychology literature that we used to gauge affect toward former combatants.
这些仪式不仅影响了相关个人，还对社区联系和凝聚力（研究人员称之为社会资本）产生了巨大影响。你知道，我们发现和解进程在治愈社区方面取得了异常巨大的成功。所以我们在这个特定的轶事中讨论了宽恕。但是当我们观察数据时，我们发现它实际上在广泛的层面上培养了宽恕。我们有从心理学文献中获得的这些指标，用来衡量对前战斗人员的情感。
And we find that, you find that people report nine months, or up to 31 months later, after these bonfire ceremonies, that they have forgiven their perpetrators to a greater degree. But they don't just feel differently. They're actually behaving differently as well. There are more friendships in the community. People say they rely on each other more for help.
我们发现，在这些篝火仪式之后9个月，甚至长达31个月，人们报告说他们在更大程度上原谅了加害者。但他们的感受不仅发生了变化。他们的行为实际上也在发生变化。社区里有了更多的友谊。人们说他们更多地依靠彼此寻求帮助。
They participate more in civic associations like PTA's and village development committees. They also contribute more to their communities. They give more to families in need. They spend more time and resources building schools and health clinics. They really changed the community orientation of their behavior. So you find that there is this extraordinary effect, as much as almost two and a half years after these ceremonies,
他们更多地参与民间协会，如家长教师联合会和村庄发展委员会。他们也为自己的社区做出了更多贡献。他们给需要帮助的家庭更多。他们花更多时间和资源建设学校和健康诊所。他们真正改变了他们行为的社区取向。因此，你发现有一种非凡的效果，在这些仪式之后长达近两年半的时间里，
that the ceremonies have brought people together, people are cooperating, more people are not just cooperating with the perpetrators, but in general, displaying all kinds of other ways in which social capital and social cohesion has increased. But you also are finding that there's a potential downside. Can you talk about that? What we find is that, you know, this process of talking about the past is actually painful
这些仪式将人们聚集在一起，人们在合作，更多的人不仅与加害者合作，而且总的来说，展示了社会资本和社会凝聚力增加的各种其他方式。但你也会发现存在潜在的负面影响。你能谈谈这个吗？我们发现，你知道，讨论过去的这个过程实际上是痛苦的，
and personally difficult for people as manifest in worsened psychological well-being in these communities. So we have three different measures that we look at, measures of anxiety, post-traumatic stress disorder, and depression. And we find that all three outcomes are actually worse in the communities that have gone through this process. And we think this is consistent with the idea that going through these memories of war in a short, intense fashion can actually reopen some old wounds.
并且对个人来说是困难的，这表现在这些社区心理健康的恶化上。所以我们研究了三个不同的指标，即焦虑症、创伤后应激障碍和抑郁症的指标。我们发现，经历过这个过程的社区的所有这三个结果实际上更糟糕。我们认为这与以下观点相一致：以一种简短、强烈的方式重温这些战争记忆，实际上可能会重新打开一些旧伤。
But when you've forgiven someone and you've made the effort to forgive someone, you would think that has a healing effect on you, that you basically, yes, you're reminded of the terrible thing that happened, but you have found a way to master it. Why isn't that not happening? It's complicated to think about how forgiveness translates into personal psychological well-being. On the one hand, it might have this healing effect. On the other hand, these war memories
但当你原谅了某人，并且付出了努力去原谅某人时，你会认为这会对你产生一种治愈的效果，基本上，是的，你被提醒了发生的糟糕事情，但你已经找到了掌控它的方法。为什么没有发生这种情况？思考宽恕如何转化为个人心理健康是复杂的。一方面，它可能有这种治愈效果。另一方面，这些战争记忆
are so potent and so powerful, and now they have been re-invoked. So you might feel better toward the person. You might be able to forgive the person for the things that they have done, but at the same time be coping with these traumatic events. We think that it's the way in which these memories are brought up in this kind of short intensive manner without follow-up for dealing with the negative images and feelings that actually lead to this worsening of the psychological outcomes. See a little bit more about that.
如此强烈和有力，现在它们被重新唤起了。所以你可能会对这个人感觉更好。你可能会因为这个人做过的事情而原谅他，但同时又在应付这些创伤性事件。我们认为，这些记忆以这种简短、强烈的方式被唤起，而没有后续措施来处理消极的形象和感觉，这实际上导致了心理结果的恶化。再多说一点。
You're saying that there's something about this process, it's a very dramatic process that might be good for social cohesion, but not so much for individuals. The reconciliation process allows people to collectively acknowledge what's happened, and allows them in a sense to be able to move on. Prior to going through this process, you know, many people avoided certain places and certain
你是说这个过程有一些特别之处，这是一个非常戏剧化的过程，可能有利于社会凝聚力，但对个人而言并非如此。和解进程使人们能够集体承认所发生的事情，并在某种程度上使他们能够继续前进。在经历这个过程之前，你知道，许多人避开了某些地方和某些
activities on account of the fact that they knew that the perpetrator, the person who was responsible for either hurting them or hurting their family members, would be present in those areas. After going through this public acknowledgement and this process of, you know, confronting what's happened, many people have been able to find closure in that event in a sense and now are ready to interact with other members of the community. This is the sense in which reconciliation can serve as a powerful force for societal healing, but at the same time these negative consequences on the individual psyche are still there. And I think the
活动，因为他们知道施害者、那个对伤害他们或他们的家人负责的人会出现在那些地方。在经历了这种公开承认和面对所发生事情的过程之后，许多人在某种程度上能够对那起事件有一个了结，现在准备好与社区的其他成员互动了。从这个意义上说，和解可以成为推动社会治愈的强大力量，但与此同时，这些对个人心理的负面影响仍然存在。我认为现在的
question now is how can we harness these very powerful societal benefits and conduct the reconciliation process in a way that mitigates the psychological impact. It may be possible, for example, to couple these types of programs with ongoing counseling so that people are able to better cope with the negative memories that are re-invoked. I'm wondering if you have a sense on why it is there has been this persistent view, maybe this is just a layman's perspective, but there's been this persistent view that forgiving other people is psychologically healthy for you. That idea that it's not just good for the perpetrator, but it's actually good for the person who's doing the forgiving is such a widespread view.
问题是，我们如何才能利用这些非常强大的社会效益，并以一种减轻心理影响的方式进行和解进程。例如，将这些类型的项目与持续的咨询相结合可能是可能的，这样人们能够更好地应对被重新唤起的负面记忆。我想知道你是否有一种感觉，为什么一直存在这样一种持久的观点，也许这只是外行人的视角，但一直存在这样一种持久的观点，即原谅他人对你的心理健康是有益的。那种不仅对加害者有益，而且对宽恕者本身也有益的想法，是一个如此广泛的观点。
And I don't think your study basically says the two things can't go together, but it says the two things don't automatically go together. That's exactly right. So in fact, there's been work in the psychology literature that shows that forgiveness is a positive psychological force. But one has to think about the positive benefit that comes from that and weigh that against some of the negative benefits that comes from reinvoking these memories. And I'm wondering in terms of your recommendation, so when you think about this, you think this is its one study,
我不认为你的研究基本上说这两者不能共存，但它说这两者不会自动地共存。完全正确。事实上，心理学文献中的工作表明，宽恕是一种积极的心理力量。但是人们必须考虑由此带来的积极效益，并将其与重新唤起这些记忆所带来的某些消极效益进行权衡。我想知道就你的建议而言，当你想到这一点时，你认为这是一项研究，
probably would have to be replicated again in maybe a different context to see if the same result holds up, but are there implications that you think that we can draw from this study and how we're thinking about reconciliation in other contexts? Absolutely. So, you know, every reconciliation process
可能必须在不同的背景下再次复制，看看同样的结果是否成立，但是你认为我们可以从这项研究以及我们如何在其他背景下思考和解中得出什么启示吗？当然。所以，你知道，每一个和解进程
has some elements that are unique, but this one has all of the core elements. So, you know, this is a context in which victims are sharing their accounts and which perpetrators are admitting to crimes in which no one is prosecuted. In that sense, it has the core elements that we think of as common to a wide range of reconciliation programs. So, you know, I do think this is something that applies to a wide range of conflicts, not just Sierra Leone, not just civil wars in Africa, but any context in which people have gone through tremendous acts of violence and now we're at a point where they need to find a way
都有一些独特的元素，但这个进程具有所有的核心元素。所以，你知道，这是一个受害者分享他们的经历，加害者承认罪行，且没有人被起诉的背景。从这个意义上说，它具有我们认为广泛的各种和解项目所共有的核心元素。所以，你知道，我确实认为这适用于广泛的冲突，不仅仅是塞拉利昂，不仅仅是非洲的内战，而是任何经历过巨大暴力行为的人们现在需要找到一种方法
of restitching together the fabric of society. I wanted to know what happened to Numa and Saur. They reconciled more than five years ago. What happened afterwards? Did Numa and Saur remain friends? Anthony Mansouré innovations for poverty action helped André-la work on the reconciliation project evaluation. He recently tracked down Numa and Saur.
来重新缝合社会结构的背景。我想知道努马和绍尔发生了什么。他们在五年前多前和解了。后来发生了什么？努马和绍尔还是朋友吗？为消除贫困创新组织工作的安东尼·曼苏尔协助安德雷拉完成了和解项目评估。他最近追踪到了努马和绍尔。
A few weeks ago, he went to their hometown in Kailahun district in Eastern Sierra Leone. Anthony found that Numa and Saur have not only stayed in touch, but they remained friends. The friend who killed the father now occasionally helps the boy whose father was killed. Anthony found that Numa and Saur have not only stayed in touch, but they've remained friends. The friend who killed the father now occasionally helps the boy whose father was killed, doing some farming and some other activities because he's not able to do this very well, given the injury to his leg. We don't know the personal psychological effects, the reconciliation ceremony has had on Numa and Saur. What we do know is that N mind helps Saur plant cassava.
几周前，他去了他们位于塞拉利昂东部凯拉洪地区的家乡。安东尼发现，努马和绍尔不仅保持着联系，而且他们仍然是朋友。那个杀害了父亲的朋友现在偶尔会帮助那个父亲被杀的男孩。安东尼发现，努马和绍尔不仅保持着联系，而且他们仍然是朋友。由于腿部受伤，那个父亲被杀的男孩无法很好地完成某些农活和其他活动，杀害了父亲的朋友现在偶尔会帮他做这些。我们不知道和解仪式对努马和绍尔产生了什么个人心理影响。我们所知道的是，努马帮助绍尔种植木薯。
They attend church together. Sometimes, they joke with one another. We begin now together. They are, after all, all friends. The film The film The film The film The
他们一起去教堂。有时，他们互相开玩笑。我们现在一起开始。毕竟，他们都是朋友。这部电影这部电影这部电影这部电影这
film The film The film The film The film The film
部电影这部电影这部电影这部电影这部电影这部
The film The film The film The film The film The film The
电影这部电影这部电影这部电影这部电影这部电影这
film The film The film The film The film The film The film The film The film The film The film The film clips from their film Fumble Talk to Anthony Mansouré from innovations for poverty action who tracked down new man Saur and to Kevin Leahy and Ahmad Omar for their voice work. You can find more of Hidden Brain on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram. Sign up for our newsletter by emailing us at hiddenbrain at npr.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. Bu videonunize iyi bakın. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
部电影这部电影这部电影这部电影这部电影这部电影这部电影这部电影这部电影这部电影这部电影这部电影剪辑自他们的电影《Fumble Talk》致谢追踪到努马和绍尔的“消除贫困创新”组织的安东尼·曼苏尔，以及为配音工作做出贡献的凯文·利海和艾哈迈德·奥马尔。你可以在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上找到更多关于“隐藏大脑”的内容。发送电子邮件至 hiddenbrain@npr.org 注册我们的时事通讯。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。请好好看看你的视频。这个节目还没有评论。点击字幕中的任何句子即可留下评论。